oh I'm sorry unfortunately it's not
possible to travel with the job I'm
sorry
if I had the option then I would offer
it but I'm sorry
a customer is far from happy about his
four-legged friend not being allowed on
the flight from London to Cologne Andre
at Siemens tries to appease him this
kind of thing is the toughest part of
her job it's important to keep a cool
head in these situations if a customer
is getting annoyed instead of letting it
get to you you try to be objective and
calm them down without getting too
emotional yeah one call center 17
languages
AIC is a workforce of 350 they serve
Airlines car rental services travel
agencies and they're the first port of
call for customer inquiries many staff
speak several languages the boss Andres
Dida which recently introduced Facebook
is a new communications channel for
customers to move requested by AI C's
biggest client Germanwings as well as
being cheaper and quicker than a phone
call the Facebook option allows
passengers to air their anger about
delays anonymously when the vid direct
quasi Fink goes straight from smartphone
to Facebook I've been waiting here for
two hours but we're not going anywhere
do you think that's good Germanwings
people what do you say to that was
active in that sue
d Jewish pays his employees 8 euros 50
per hour
not a great wage in Germany but still
more than other call centers they give
the sector a bad image he says you have
a bunch of course we're in an industry
that gets pretty bad press generally a
lot of call centers are in sales that
work is all about making a sale people
are put in situations that are not
always agreeable and that's why you see
certain negative ideas and prejudices
about call centers to build on for Talal
dieter age set up his company 20 years
ago cologne was a good choice of
location due to its multinational
multilingual population it's not hard to
find employees who speak three or four
languages many of his clients are based
here at cologne Bonn Airport that
clientele is growing as Airlines and car
rental firms pulled the plug on cheaper
call centers abroad in favor of those at
home finishing I'm freelancing if I'm in
an emerging nation where workers
themselves have never taken a trip then
I have to explain to them what travel
entails what are the routes and modes of
transportation in a foreign country
these are fundamental things that we
don't have to discuss with German
employees because they just know them
engage is Goodyear Muslim riders kindy
alpha
call center operators are evaluated
regularly by professionals to perfect
their phone mannerisms you set the word
sorry about three times in a row
try to avoid that otherwise you're
constantly apologizing just try to cut
words like sorry or unfortunately out of
your vocabulary altogether that makes
sense okay I'll try to do that at the
end of an eight-hour shift you can
finally rest your tongue and her ears
that's what I do love to chat but I'm
glad when I can just listen when you can
just nod and not have to explain things
that's understandable after all she just
booked or cancelled flights for more
than 100 customers and answered a
barrage of questions
you